[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de la
crise écologique
la crise écologique c'est une extinction
rapide et massive de la biodiversité et
c'est ce qui se passe à l'échelle
planétaire comme en témoigne l'évolution
de l'indicé de la planète vivante qui
montrent une érosion de plus de 50% sur
les 40 dernières années alors présenté
comme ça ça paraît particulièrement
alarmant mais en fait c'est la sixième
crise biologique depuis la naissance de
la terre en revanche c'est la première
qui est d'origine anthropique
ça veut dire que c'est la première dans
les hommes sent responsable et
aujourd'hui on a particulièrement
conscience de cette responsabilité et
cela se traduit par de nombreux débats
au niveau de la société comme en
témoigne le nombre d' le nombre
d'articles mentionnons le terme
biodiversité publiée dans le quotidien
le monde entre 1990 et 2015
nous assistons à une explosion de ce
sujet sur la scène médiatique
alors tous ces débats ne sont pas restés
lettre morte
ils ont conduit à de nombreux programmes
politiques au niveau international comme
nationaux pourtant malgré la prise de
conscience
malgré les débats et malgré les actions
politiques
les indicateurs de la biodiversité reste
particulièrement alarmant alors la
question que j'aimerais vous poser
aujourd'hui c'est que pouvons-nous faire
face à cette crise et pour cela je vous
propose une petite expérience de pensée
alors pour cette expérience de pensée
il faut imaginer que vous êtes
responsable d'un territoire et plus
particulièrement d'un territoire de
montagne où il y as en aval de la vallée
une grande ville qui est le poumon
économique de la région
et puis en amont de la vallée il ya un
petit village qui est aujourd'hui isolé
avec des riverains qui sont assez mais
contente parce que ils mettent trop
temps pour voir rejoindre la grande
ville alors vous
en tant que responsable vous avez la
possibilité d'améliorer le sort de ces
riverains en construisant une route et
là vous avez trois options soit vous
faites ça vous fait une route par la
vallée soit vous faites une route qui
passe par un tunnel ou bien vous faites
une route qui passe vers le col alors
qui est moins rapide que les deux
précédentes mais qui est quand même plus
rapide que ce qui existe aujourd'hui la
question que j'aimerais vous poser c'est
qu'est-ce que vous choisiriez est-ce que
vous choisiriez de ne rien faire ou
est-ce que vous choisirez de construire
une route
et si oui quelle route alors je vous
invite à noter dans le coin de votre
tête
l'option que vous choisiriez comme ça
spontanément avant que nous y
réfléchissions ensemble
alors si c'est bon je vous propose donc
de réfléchir ensemble à comment nous
pourrions effectuer ce choix alors tout
d'abord pouvoir effectuer ce choix il
faut comprendre comprendre comment
fonctionne ce territoire parce que ce
territoire il ya de la vie il n'est pas
inerte
il ya par exemple des arbres qui
poussent en fonction de la qualité des
sols et puis ces arbres ils vont donner
des conditions d'humidité des conditions
de luminosité tout ça ça va créer des
conditions pédoclimatiques qui doit être
favorable à certaines espèces et c'est
le cas par exemple de certains chevreuil
qui s'épanouissent dans cette forêt et
puis le haut de la montagne présente des
conditions pédoclimatiques qui sont
certes plus rude mais qui peuvent être
favorable à d'autres espèces c'est le
cas par exemple de l'ours
alors aujourd'hui nous connaissons le
fonctionnement des écosystèmes leur
équilibre et dynamique grâce aux
sciences de la terre et du vivant
et puis dans ce territoire il ya des
hommes ces hommes ils ont une dynamique
propre également est par exemple cette
belle forêt avec ses beaux arbres et
sebo chevreuil attire pas mal de
touristes alors en réponse à ces
touristes
un petit malin de la grande ville a eu
l'idée d'ouvrir un restaurant d'altitude
alors lui typiquement il a pris une
décision qui va dépendre du coût de la
main d'oeuvre du prix du terrain
et puis du nombre de touristes qu'il
espère avoir mais tous les toutes les
tous les mouvements humains ne résulte
pas de décision économique
on a par exemple des pèlerins qui
considère la montagne comme sacrée et
qui aime aller se recueillir dans une
chapelle en haut de la montagne
aujourd'hui ces dynamiques sociales sont
étudiées par les sciences humaines et
sociales et en fait
en combinant les sciences de la terre et
du vivant avec les sciences humaines et
sociales
nous pouvons avoir une connaissance du
fonctionnement des socios écosystèmes
c'est à dire des systèmes qui intègre à
la fois les éléments naturels et les
éléments humains alors vous allez me
dire à quoi ça sert cette connaissance
cette connaissance est essentiel parce
que ça va me permettre de comprendre les
conséquences des différentes options qui
s'offrent à moi
reprenons notre exemple et puis prenons
la première route qui passe par la
vallée cette route va conduire un
déboisement partielle de la vallée qui
va impacter la population de chevreuils
avec une superficie plus réduite et avec
moins de chevreuil à l'intérieur cette
forêt est moins attractive d'un point de
vue touristique
du coup le nombre de touristes va
diminuer ainsi que l'activité du petit
restaurateur
voici donc le territoire que nous
obtiendrions si nous choisissions
l'option route par la vallée considérons
maintenant l'option route par le tunnel
alors c'est une elle n'affecte pas du
tout un la zone forestière en revanche
parce qu'il a été construit ce tunnel il
a déstabilisé les sols et aujourd'hui
certaines parties de la montagne sont
risqués à cause des boules y est bien
sûr pas de chance le terrain sur lequel
est construit le petit restaurant et
sujet assez éboulis
le restaurateur se voit donc dans
l'obligation de fermer son restaurant et
ce bien qu'il ya encore des touristes à
restaurer potentiellement mais le
restaurateur n'est pas le seul à faire
les frais de ce tunnel puisque en fait
les pèlerins qui considère la montagne
comme sacrés sont complètement mécontent
de voir leur montagne sacrée percée en
son sein comme ça voici donc le
territoire que nous obtiendrions si nous
choisissions l'option route par le
tunnel et puis enfin la troisième option
qui est la route par le col qui
n'affecte ni la zone faurecia ni les
pèlerins mais qui comme le vous le voyez
affecte la zone de reproduction des ours
qui voient donc leurs effectifs diminuer
on se retrouve donc avec quatre options
qui vont conduire à quatre territoires
ou 4 sociaux écosystèmes différents
alors quel choix effectué riez vous
maintenant que vous avez cette nouvelle
connaissance
est-ce que ce choix est identique à
celui que vous aviez fait spontanément
au début de la conférence
et puis est-ce que ce choix vous semble
plus facile maintenant que vous avez
accès à cette nouvelle connaissance
alors figurez vous que je ne serai pas
du tout surprise si vous trouvez que
c'est pas forcément plus facile
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ces
connaissances elles nous permettent de
comprendre les conséquences de nos
actions
mais elle ne permet pas de juger ses
conséquences elles ne permettent pas de
dire qu'est ce qui est mieux qu est ce
qui est moins bien
qu'est ce qui est préférable ou qu'est
ce qui ne l'est pas en fait pour cela
il faut comprendre le moteur les moteurs
sous jacent à nos décisions et ses
moteurs il se trouve dans des valeurs
alors une valeur
c'est ce qui va guider mon choix parce
que c'est digne d'intérêt pour moi parce
que ça va m'apporter par exemple de
l'utilité de la satisfaction ou du
revenu alors ses valeurs elle n'existe
pas comme ça dans la nature ses valeurs
elle émane d'un jugement humain je vous
propose de revenir notre paysage et de
regarder où est ce qu'il ya des humains
susceptibles d'avoir des valeurs alors
il y en a un certain nombre et
commençons par les riverains de la
petite ville qui était mécontent
alors quand on dit qu'ils sont
mécontents en fait implicitement ont dit
qu'ils attribuent une valeur autant
perdu dans les transports
parce que allah au lieu de perdre du
temps dans les transports il pourrait
faire autre chose qui leur apportent
plus de satisfaction comme être avec
leurs enfants aller courir ou même
travail éventuellement ainsi pour eux un
bon choix
ça va être un choix qui minimise le
temps passé dans les transports
et puis nous avons ces touristes qui
aiment aller dans la dans la forêt
implicitement cela signifie qu'ils
attribuent une valeur récréative à cette
forêt mais ces touristes ne sont pas les
seuls à attribuer une valeur à la forêt
en effet l'activité économique du petit
restaurant dépend indirectement de cette
forêt pourquoi parce que cette activité
dépend de la présence de touristes qui
elle même dépend de la présence de la
forêt ainsi le restaurateur attribue une
valeur d'usagé indirecte à la forêt et
puis nous avons ce pèlerin comme la vue
qui a trait qui considère la montagne
quand comme sacrés ou qui en d'autres
termes attribue une valeur spirituelle à
la montagne et pour finir imaginons un
riverain qui vit dans la grande ville
qui ne va jamais dans la campagne aux
alentours mais qui malgré tout
attribue une valeur d'existence à l'ours
cela signifie que il a conscience que
l'ours existait dans cette campagne
avant sa naissance qu'il a envie que
l'espèce continue à exister au delà de
sa mort alors que faisons nous
maintenant avec ses valeurs comment
faire un choix
et bien pour faire un choix il faut en
fait
combinez le moteur des décisions avec
les conséquences des différentes options
en d'autres termes il faut combiner les
valeurs avec la connaissance sur le
fonctionnement des socios écosystèmes
pour illustrer le procédé je vous
propose de revenir à notre expérience de
pensée et de prendre d'abord une seule
valeur la valeur d'existence de l'ours
alors on regarde les conséquences des
différentes options sur l'ours et on
voit que l'option qui est la route par
le col n'est pas satisfaisante je vais
donc l'exclure ainsi un bon choix
cohérent avec la valeur d'existence de
l'ours sera une des trois autres options
je peux complexifié et rajouter une
deuxième valeur par exemple la valeur du
temps perdu dans les transports
alors la première option qui est pas de
route n'est pas satisfaisante de ce
point de vue là je vais donc l'exclure
il me reste donc deux options
disponibles
si je veux satisfaire ce binôme de
valeur et ainsi de suite
alors je rajoute une troisième valeur
qui va être la valeur et créatif de la
forêt et je me rends compte que la
l'option par la vallée n'est pas
satisfaisante
alors là vous voyez arriver plus je
rajoute de valeur et plus je prends le
risque que je n'ai plus d'options que je
n'ai plus d'options disponibles pour
faire un choix satisfaisant mon un
ensemble de valeurs et c'est le cas si
je rajoute la valeur spirituelle de la
montagne la dernière option n'est pas
satisfaisante
je me retrouve donc dans une situation
qui semble bloquée avec aucune option
est disponible
alors comment faire un choix dans ce cas
là je vous propose de réfléchir à cette
histoire de valeur
les valeurs c'est ce qui va guider notre
décision est ce qui est important pour
nous mais peut-être que certaines
valeurs sont plus importantes pour nous
c'est ce qu'on appelle les valeurs
fondamentales
l'idée c'est alors de refaire le même
raisonnement combiné connaissance et
valeur et en se focalisant sur les
valeurs fondamentales
alors comme on tient pas compte de
toutes les valeurs on peut pas encore
faire un choix
mais en revanche on peut déterminer
quelque chose et ce quelque chose
s'appelle un domaine de viabilité un
domaine de viabilité
c'est l'ensemble des options qui sont
satisfaisantes
du point de vue des valeurs
fondamentales reprenons notre exemple
réfléchissons aux valeurs et imaginons
que la valeur fondamentale est la valeur
d'existence de l'ours
ainsi je vais éliminé l'option qui n'est
pas satisfaisante et en corollaire
déterminé mon domaine de viabilité qui
est ici
construit à partir de trois options il
s'agit ensuite de se focaliser dans ce
domaine de viabilité et de refaire le
même raisonnement combinant connaissance
et valeur en intégrant les autres
valeurs mais on se focalise ans dans le
domaine de viabilité
vous allez me dire oui mais on a vu tout
à l'heure que ces valeurs n'étaient pas
compatibles certaines d'entre elles sont
antagonistes
on va être dans la même situation et
c'est vrai on ne va pas pouvoir faire un
choix directement
il va d'abord y avoir un processus de
négociations entre les différents
porteurs des différentes valeurs
de là va émerger un choix qui va être au
sein du domaine de viabilité et c'est en
ce sens que ce sera un bon choix parce
qu'on se rassure qu'il va satisfaire les
valeurs fondamentales d'un autre exemple
nous reprenons le domaine de viabilité
nous intégrons les trois dernières
valeurs émerge un processus de
négociations par exemple entre le
syndicat du tourisme et le syndicat de
la restauration
et puis un choix émergent ce choix ne
peut pas satisfaire l'ensemble des
valeurs mais comme il a lieu au sein du
domaine de viabilité
on est sûr qu'il va vérifier la valeur
mental qui est ici la valeur d'existence
de l'ours
alors pour conclure je vous propose de
revenir à notre question initiale
que pouvons-nous faire face à la crise
moi je pense que face à la crise
on peut faire quelque chose d'essentiel
on peut choisir
nous avons vu que le choix était la
combinaison de trois éléments la
connaissance les valeurs dont certaines
sont fondamentales et un processus de
négociation pour arbitrer entre les
antagonistes
alors où en sommes nous aujourd'hui du
point de vue de la connaissance nous
avons beaucoup progressé nous
connaissons bien
depuis une trentaine d'années le
fonctionnement des socios écosystèmes et
puis nous avons de fabuleuses instance
de négociation
elles ne sont pas parfaites mais elle
commence de plus en plus à se développer
comme par exemple la cap 21
en revanche ce qui manque à mon avis
c'est un vrai débat explicite sur les
valeurs alors pourquoi je dis explicite
parce qu'en fait ces valeurs elles
existent parce que s'il n'y avait pas de
valeur il n'y aurait pas de choix mais
aujourd'hui elles sont cachées elles
sont encapsulés elles sont calculées
soit dans la connaissance scientifique
qui vise à donner des solutions clés en
main aux décideurs politiques ou bien
encapsulé dans les processus de
négociations et donc coloré de rapport
de force
pourtant un vrai débat explicite sur les
valeurs nous permettrait d'avancer face
à la crise et ce pour trois raisons
tout d'abord on se rendrait compte qui a
des valeurs sur lesquelles avec
lesquelles on est d'accord et cela
permettrait d'augmenter le degré
d'adhésion à certains de mesures
politiques parce qu'aujourd'hui at un
programme politique sans perçus comme
des contraintes mais en fait si on
expliciter les valeurs qui sont
sous-jacentes
on se rendrait compte que c'est pas des
contraintes mais la conséquence
naturelle de valeurs avec lesquelles
nous sommes en accord
le deuxième point c'est qu'on se
rendrait compte qu'il ya des valeurs sur
lesquelles on n'est pas d'accord
mais les expliciter avec précision
permettrait à mon avis d'avancé sur la
compréhension et la gestion de cette
crise et enfin
expliciter ces valeurs nous permettrait
de sortir d'une position passive face à
la crise pour adopter une position
active parce qu'en fait face à la crise
on peut faire vraiment ce que l'on veut
vraiment on peut faire ce qu'on veut
mais il faudrait seulement que l'on
comprenne ce que l'on veut parce que
c'est la condition sinequanone vous
construire une nouvelle réalité avec
laquelle nous serions un accord
[Applaudissements]